jt se suscribió a un plan de mensajes de
texto para su celular con otros tres
miembros de su familia en cualquier mes
no puede mandar más de 500 mensajes de
texto en total eso lo voy a subrayar
porque es importante no puede mandar más
de 500 mensajes de texto en total y
ahora dice al final del mes
jt había mandado 25 mensajes más que su
hermana mayor también lo voy a subrayar
porque es un dato importante es una
información importante había mandado 25
mensajes más que su hermana mayor 50
mensajes menos que su hermana menor y
125 más que su mamá la pregunta es
cuántos mensajes de texto pudo haber
mandado jt si no excedieron el límite de
los 500 mensajes de texto entonces
cuántos mensajes de texto pudo haber
mandado jt si no excedieron el límite
okey excelente ya tenemos aquí la
información que necesitamos los
subrayado es lo esencial y lo que vamos
a hacer es definir algunas variables
digamos qué
es igual al número de mensajes de texto
que hizo la hermana mayor entonces o es
igual al número de mensajes de texto de
la hermana mayor y ahora bien es igual
al número de mensajes de texto mensajes
de texto de la hermana menor usaremos m
de mamá
entonces m es igual al número de
mensajes de texto m es igual al número
de mensajes de texto de la mamá de jt y
ahora ya solamente falta jt entonces voy
a definir a jota jota es igual al número
de mensajes por jt y ok
el total de mensajes de texto que todos
se enviaron no pudo no puede ser más que
500 no puede exceder los 500 si sumamos
los mensajes de jota más los de la
hermana mayor más los de la hermana
menor y más los de la mamá de jt la suma
debe ser esta suma debe ser
igual un menor que 500 eso es importante
debe ser menor o igual que 500 tal vez
si excede la cantidad de 500 le cobren
más o no lo sé pero pero como como
podemos expresar cada una de estas
variables en términos de la cantidad de
mensajes que envió jt aquí nos dan
información dice que jt había mandado 25
mensajes más que su hermana mayor
esto lo ponemos de esta manera jota es
igual a 25 más la cantidad de mensajes
que mandó su hermana mayor
eso sería entonces jota es igual a 25
más
y también nos dice que jt mandó 50
textos menos que su hermana menor
entonces jota es igual a ye menos 50 y
finalmente jota te envío 125 mensajes
más que su mamá esto se pone de esta
manera jota es igual a m más 125 y muy
bien queremos esta expresión en términos
de j así que lo que voy a hacer para
para expresar lo en términos de j es
despejar cada una de las variables la
ola yei la m vamos a despejar esas y ya
sustituimos después de eso entonces
hagamos esto hagamos esto sí jota es
igual a 25 más o simplemente vamos a
restar 25 de ambos lados de la ecuación
y obtenemos jota menos 25 es igual a 1
simplemente restamos 25 de ambos lados
ahora vamos con el siguiente sumamos 50
aquí vamos a sumar 50 de ambos lados de
la ecuación y lo que vamos a obtener es
jota más 50 es igual a y finalmente lo
que hacemos aquí es restar 125 de ambos
lados de la ecuación obtenemos el número
de mensajes enviados por su mamá
entonces m aquí restando 125 tenemos que
jota menos 125 es igual a m ok entonces
aquí lo que dice es que jt envió 125
mensajes más que su hermana mayor tomás
la cantidad de mensajes que envió jt
restas 25
y obtienes la cantidad de mensajes que
envió la hermana mayor ahora de igual
manera envío 50 textos menos que su
hermana menor tomas los mensajes que
envió jota más 50 es igual a la cantidad
de mensajes que envió su hermana y para
la mamá resta 125 jota menos 125 es
igual a m ahora sí podemos sustituir
estas variables en la ecuación original
entonces tenemos jota más o pero jota es
igual a jota menos 25 entonces voy a
poner j menos 25 aquí jota menos 25 más
pero hoy es igual a jota más 50 ajam
entonces pongo aquí voy a sustituir jota
más 50 y ahora m entonces m es igual a
jota menos 125 más jota menos 125 todo
esto debe ser menor o igual que 500
ahora simplemente vamos a sumar las
jotas tenemos 1 2 3 y 4 j
j ahora vamos a sumar las constantes
tenemos menos menos 25 menos 25 más 50
esto es igual a 25 positivo 25 positivo
menos 125
esto sería igual esto es igual a menos
100 entonces menos 104 jota menos 100 es
menor o igual que 500 muy bien ahora
vamos a sumar de ambos lados de la
ecuación 100 sumamos 100 de ambos lados
obtenemos esto se cancela obtenemos 4
jota es menor o igual que 600 dividimos
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 4 y
obtenemos que jota aquí voy a ponerlo
acá abajo jota es menor o igual que 150
y ahí lo tenemos
jt envío envió 150 mensajes o menos en
este mes entonces de esa manera las
hermanas jt y la mamá enviaron 500
mensajes o menos y no excedieron el
límite muy bien nos vemos